good day everybody and welcome i'm jack
van horn from the university of virginia
i'm proud to welcome you to this edition
of our 2021 2022 foundations of
biomedical data science seminar series
the lecture series is supported by uva's
integrated translational health
institute of virginia the uva brain
institute the
uva college of arts and sciences the
school of data science and through a
grant from the national institutes of
general medical sciences this year's
theme is the ethical challenges of
artificial intelligence biomedicine
where we will enjoy presentations on
fridays from leading thinkers about the
promise opportunities and hurdles
associated with ai applications in the
biomedical sciences selected
participants in our biomedical data
science innovation lab program will
leverage these presentations as vital
material for our culminating in-person
grant development workshop but to be
held here in beautiful charlottesville
virginia next june
applications for the biomedical data
science innovation lab are still being
accepted until january 31st 2022 that is
on monday end of day on monday so if you
are interested or you have junior
faculty colleagues who are interested
please encourage them to submit their
materials
and you can do so at the link provided
on the screen
today
i am
absolutely delighted to welcome our
speaker
dr atlanta garmeyer from the university
of michigan
lana is an associate professor in the
department of computational medicine and
bioinformatics at the university of
michigan her translational
bioinformatics research areas include
single cell bioinformatics multimodal
data integration of complex diseases
using genomics imaging and emr data and
drug reposition
she has published over 80 papers in
leading journals including cell as well
as nature and she's delivered over 70
invited talks to institutes including
the national library medicine and the
national academy of sciences she served
on various nih study sections and
currently is a standing member of the
bdma studies section she's on the
editorial advisory board for genome
biology and the journal of proteome
research and she was an awardee of the
us presidential early career scientists
and engineers
award in 2019
the research that her group um
pursues has been funded by the nih for
over the last past 10 years
in continuing our with our theme of
biomedical data science
in ethical challenges in artificial
intelligence biomedicine atlanta's
lecture today is entitled current
practice challenges and perspectives on
single cell data science
single cell sequencing is now innate has
now enabled the study of many complex
biological systems at an unprecedented
level of resolution in her talk today
atlanta will be first overviewing the
working principle of single cell rna-seq
the most dominant form of single cell
data she will also show the steps of a
typical single cell rna-seq analysis
including pre-processing and downstream
function analysis she'll demonstrate how
the next generation single cell rna-seq
meta analytics and now
meta analytic tools engage both
bioinformaticians and bench scientists
and she'll conclude by noting ongoing
challenges and the very technological
perspectives which
are present in the field
as always we are streaming this lecture
live and for recording via youtube if
you are watching on youtube thank you so
much for joining us also our specially
selected 2021 2022 biomedical data
science innovation lab participants
strongly encouraged to submit their
questions for lana via the chat feature
in their zoom sessions i'll synthesize
these questions and ask
those questions on your behalf during
the last 10 minutes or so of the lecture
and without further ado dr gar meyer
thank you so much we are very much
looking forward to your lecture
first i was just just gonna um outline
the presentation today
um i'm gonna give a brief introduction
under the background of the single cell
uh biomedical field
and then you know we always as data
scientists uh we are
necessary to understand where those data
are generated from how are they
generated from
and then i will spend the most majority
of the time to talk about some typical
single cell artistic analysis workflows
as you may know that a single cell
rna-seq is one of the most dominant form
of the single cell genomics data types
and near the end that i will briefly
mention about some other single cell
research areas and the current
ongoing challenges and the perspectives
for the field to move forward
so i'd like to think that
you have some
very basic
biology or genomics background if you
don't for some reason please be at dm me
or email me
um
i also assume that you're very
interested in this field and perhaps
you're even starting to do single-cell
bioinformatics research
so this is a slider that i really
often i use
to introduce about this topic
why do i need to do single sale
uh here
this is a picture i got from twitter i'm
pretty active on twitter's community as
you can see you know
here on the top is the image of a
dinosaur it has certain features
mean and the standard deviation and
correlation among different data points
on the bottom there are 12 images they
have exactly the same features
as the dinosaur however they're by no
means dinosaurs
so this is the dynamic that we used to
face
when we did bulk sequencing technology
where you ground everything up
and take the average
but you don't know the detail and as we
know now that the devils are really in
the details
in fact
single-cell are sticker has been so
important that it was being
named the breakthrough technology of the
year 2018 by science
more recently
the spatial transatomics
another new technology has been named
the breakthrough of the year 2020
and here i'm showing you a very
beautiful picture
from a
dr drumway waste group where they
developed a new methodology called
murfish that allows researchers to zoom
into individual cells to have very sick
very finite single cell resolution and
look at all
over 10 thousand genes expression
simultaneously among various cells
and at the same time you will have this
spatial resolution which is really
really wonderful
in fact
this technology is not
success
overnight it has a history at least 10
years
here is a paper that was published
almost 10 years ago
and the author had a very bold title
single cell sequencing based
technologies will revolutionize the
whole organism science
and now in retrospect that stimulus is
really true
and the authors predicted several
domains of discoveries that can be
widely
used or found by single cell
technologies for example you can reveal
genomic variations among individual
cells
and you could reconstruct the cellular
ancestries in the form of an image tree
and you could also study the functional
states of individual cells
you can discover new cell types
using single cell technology
also the authors rightfully predicted
that you can now simultaneously analyze
genomics transcriptomics and genomic
states of the cells
so to speak multi-omics in single cell
and finally
they stated that
this these new technologies were shed
light on fundamental questions of
biology and medicine which is really
very much the core of the technologies
applications
so
here is the landscape of the single cell
research which is becoming more and more
complex every single day
so here i'm showing you a hierarchical
tree you know starting with this domain
so called single cell research
depending on the data that you generated
have a spatial resolution or non-special
revolution it can divide can be divided
into non-special mix and special mix
under under non-special mix depending on
how many types of omics data are
generated it can be subdivided into
single omics or multi-omics
and under the single omics depending on
the types of data
it can be
either a single cell rnsq or a single
cell exome sequence or single cell dna
methylation
and on the other hand on the spatial
omics platform now most dominantly for
most dominated form is single omics but
also most recently last year there's a
new platform that allows one to do
multi-omics
at the same time
under the spatial contact so as you can
see the the the landscape is getting
very very complex
and for the purpose of today's
presentation i'm just going to focus on
single cell rnc
so this is a brief overview of the
history of single-cell and signal
technology it came a long way
starting sometime around 2009
and it went
over time the
the number of the cells that can be
studied
has increased
in a long linear fashion
and some of the key points i like to you
know point out is
why is a smart seek technology which was
used later in fluiden
fluidim is a technology that was very
prominent and has a full length
sequencing capacity
it was very very popular in 2014
and then later on other
labs
started to develop other technologies
for example dropseek
some of you would have must have heard
and most importantly
10x genomics is a commercial company
that
made the single cell technology as a lab
use in a ordinary database
so this is
currently the most dominated
platform if not at the most dominated
platform
so of course because those technologies
have different uh uh protocols to begin
with they have different features right
some of them can measure the full body
of mra some of them have strength
specificity some of them have bias
towards the three primary uh
through prime end of the mri transcript
some of them ask you know as the
resolution of umi labeled a resolution
very specific
here
i'm just going to give you a very
brief overview of the single cell resig
data generated by tanx genomics
so this is a workflow
from getting the sample to getting the
data matrix of single cell experiment
i can
divide it roughly into two parts
experimental part and computational part
for data scientists what we care most is
computational part but also i think it's
necessary to introduce the experimental
part very briefly so that you know
what kind of you know features the data
have and why it's challenging and then
also at the same time interesting to
analyze single cell data
so here's a
workflow of the experimental part
so kx uses a
it's a microfluid device basically what
it does is to have this kind of a gel
based uh
gel based beads
each of the bead look
is shown here it has so-called barcode
on your umi that can be tagged on
a specific mri transcript
so
when
when you do the experiment thanks
experiment
what happens is that those gel beads
will go through one channel and then the
cells will be fed
into this
perpendicular channel and a fuse
with those gel beads
and also next they will go to a oil
phase where
the gel beads and the cell individual
single cells will be encapsulated into
oil bubble
and so this kind of encapsulation allows
a biochemical enzyme reaction happen and
then here is the next step
uh
you collected those those gel beads
individually into your oil bubble and
you do reverse transcript
switching
and what happens that those individual
cells now are like
last and then the mrnas are being uh
being amplified the signals will come
out
and so after that
you get those
you get those all your bubbles to be uh
popped up and then becomes a solution
and things through the whole thing into
a sequencer machine so at the end
what we get
out of the sequence of machine
is
for
x number of cells you have wide number
of genes being expressed
so here is a graphic example to show you
know uh the kind of things that come out
that you have each gene will have a
certain number of reads and we use that
read number to help us
to
form this data matrix raw data matrix
[Music]
so
tx has its own
platform to do the upstream data
processing
using cell ranger
so what did happen briefly in cell
ranger is that you know fast q reads
data coming from sequencing machine
will be aligned
by this pro this is a a liner called a
star
of course you know our field has
many other alignment tools but it's not
a today's topic
um
tx use star for the alignment after that
you will uh come to the transcripts and
then form this kind of gene cell matrix
and here is a dummy example of the gene
cell matrix as you can see you know
some of the cells
have zero expression of
certain gene but non-zero expression of
some other genes so this kind of zero
can be truth and it can be artifacts
and when this artifact recorded dropout
event
so briefly the characteristics of single
cyclistic data are the following
the data matrix are sparse there are a
lot of zeros they're very noisy because
of the technology limitation they have
very high dropout rates up to 50 to 70
percent
and they're also affected by very
significant batch effects
some of the best effects are known some
are very difficult to control
experimentally and needs to be adjusted
computationally
and also those data metrics they can
come from different methodologies
besides 10x platform
and as we already know this field has
been exploding
uh the data science that are generated
from single cell studies are really
growing rapidly
and so on and so forth
so here's a picture to show you you know
some of the characteristics of the
single cell data so here's a scatter
plot of two
cells that come from the same tissue
type
the scatter plot as you can see
you know
this kind of event here
where some genes
are showing up in one cell but not in
other cells they're called called
dropout events and also another very
unique phenomenon is over dispersion in
single cell data
currently there have been some
pretty mature
single stick analysis software kits
the most well-known one is called
surrett
and then also there's monocle
and the scampi
surat is developed
by new york genome center pi
satisha
and it is our package
it has a very comprehensive functions
going from qc
to analysis exploration over the single
crx data and nowadays even integration
with spatialomix data
so it has very
well documented it's very well
documented very well maintained they
also have workshop
for the users to get started it has
built-in functions to read the text
genomics data
it also also implemented most of the
steps needed in the common analysis so
it's very comprehensive toolkit
so here is an example
of some of the uh
single theoretical analysis pipeline
here i'm showing you one example those
pipelines depending on the user's need
very here and there but
there are certain themes and features
modules that are in common
for this particular pipeline you start
uploading the single cell data
and you go through steps of improving
imputation normalization filtering the
genes
and filtering in cells and node
transformation some of the packages
require log transformation
so this part is the pre-processing and
that stream would be you know more like
a functional analysis related to biology
so what usually happens is you know
users will do dimension reduction
and then after dimension reduction they
would use tools to visualize
the sub populations in single cell data
and
the different subpopulations can then
undergo differential expression analysis
and also marketing identification
and also at the same time
for those different subpopulations they
are done by using different clustering
approach
for different clusters you may want to
find out what exactly the cell type they
are
so there's next step
that's optional it's called annotation
also some of the traditionally bulk
level analysis tools or methods
can also be adapted here in single cell
analysis for example gene study
enrichment analysis for example protein
protein network analysis and another
thing that is very very unique about
single cell analysis allows
us it allows us to do pseudo-time
reconstruction as well
so here's the second
example of single-cell artistic analysis
pipeline here the users divided them
into three different
functional
groups preprocessing similarly
you do quantity control cell and a gene
filtering normalization and then you do
clustering identify variable genes
dimension reduction
identify marker genes and clustering and
then downstream interpret the biology to
get a differentially expressed genes
assign different cell type and then
other functional annotations for example
pseudotime reconstruction
so here's a third way without going into
the detail i'm just going to bypass this
because it really uh it's very similar
for the majority part
of the analysis
modules
so this is the first step for quality
control
and filtering
so quality control
why why do we do quality control as we
know that the single cell data they are
they are uh poor quality uh they have a
lot of noises so you need to filter out
the cells or the genes that are of poor
quality first
and also
in the
preparation of those samples sometimes
the cells undergo a lot of stress
and so by looking at the mitochondria
gene reads it's a good way to filter out
the cells that have gone
through a lot of stress and you can
emulate them
and also another reason is to remove the
cells with protocols like like i just
mentioned so to do that you can use the
filter approach
uh you can filter the cells with
certain percentage of microcontroller
reads higher than a cutoff
and here down here is an example so
here's a plot that shows you the
intensity shows you the the mitochondria
counts
you know the higher the value is in
those different data points each of the
data point is a cell so the higher the
color is the most stressed out the cell
is so you can utilize certain threshold
to remove those cells that are
have a lot of stress
uh also
users often use different filtering
approach to filter the cells with less
and lower threshold on the number of
genes or number of cells as you can see
here so you have two threshold on two
dimensions with a number of gene based
on the number of genes and a basic
number of cell counts
um another type of
quality control um is called a doublet
removal
why do we need to remove double down how
do they even come out
sometimes
when we prepare this kind of a single
cell droplets occasionally two cells or
even more than two cells can
accidentally go into one droplet
and so those cells those results are
obviously they're not a single cell
resolution there are multiple cell
resolutions so they need to be removed
and
most recently
there has been a very serious benchmark
study
that evaded
eight different dropout
detection methods and the author claimed
that a doubling the finder
using a comprehensive set of metrics
here
they claimed that the double defender is
the best method
so this field
of doublet removal
is getting more and more mature which is
a good thing
next i'm going to briefly talk about
normalization why do we even want to do
normalization normalization is to
correct for the second step variations
from different single cells
if we do not correct the section that
bias then
they're like oranges and apples you
cannot compare them across the board
so the most simple way to do
normalization as coded in surat
is to normalize gene expression for each
of the cell by total number of reads
and then you multiply by some scaling
factor for example 10 000 reads
and then you can do log 2 transformation
on the scaled
counts
so that's the most simple way of
normalization
after you do the field filtering or
normalization of those reads then we can
do you know more interesting data
analysis one of the first steps of of
the data analysis is to reduce the
dimension
um
for folks who study genomics we know
very well that you know uh genomics data
have this curse of a high dimensionality
it has a lot of features
to begin with so it's necessary to
reduce the features to the ones that are
really embedding biological information
so here are two examples of the commonly
used dimension reduction method the one
on the left is called pca we all know
that a pc is to transform the features
into linear orthogonal space principal
components
and on the right hand is called umapu
uniform manifold approximation and
projection so new map
and sometimes the disney are used to
help
the authors to present their data down
to two dimensional space as you can see
here
but the advantage
of umap over t-sne is that it preserves
the local structure and also global
structure better
but bear in mind
both those types of dimension reduction
methods they're non-linear so you cannot
really directly understand the distance
meaning on the two dimension
the distance for example between the
blue versus the orange
versus the red what exactly mean it's
not a linear term
but it's a good way to have a
visualization
so recently there has been a very uh
comprehensive benchmark study
to look at the
many different dimension reduction
methods
from my colleague dr joshian's group in
universe michigan biostat department
and here as the hidden map shows you
know
there are good
good methods intermediate behavior
measures and poor methods
as you can see here pca and umapple as i
demonstrated to you earlier they
actually
among the very top or very distant
methods for dimension reduction
[Music]
so after dimension that reduction
what happened next is clustering
there are also
many many many many classroom messages
we are not lacking clustering method
in the single cell data science field
but in this benchmark study what it
shows in common
is that surat and sc3
the clustering methods that embedded in
encoded in strata and sd3 are among the
top performing methods
so surat's
clustering method it's a using the
graph-based approach
and sc3
i'm showing you the citation here it is
a consensus classroom approach
after clustering
you visualize your data this way
and then you know surround or
other program can give you different
clusters
and then what happened next
which is very interesting to biologists
is to identify
what those cell types are for each of
the clusters or sometimes
you know one cell type can actually have
several different clusters called sub
populations
so this process
is called cell type annotation
as you can see here one example
you go from unannotated
clustering to annotated
cell types
there have been
many different cell type of annotation
methods
automatic an automatic cell type of
annotation methods
already
also bear in mind at the same time you
know the end the users they like to have
their own biomarkers and they do manual
uh
cell type annotation as well but that
really doesn't scale up and it doesn't
really help to identify new new cell
types or rare setups new rare cell types
so one of the example is a single r
single r method it has this three
different steps
so what it has is to use the unannotated
single cell rna data
and borrow the strings coming from the
reference
transcriptomics that has
identified a pure cell type information
use that as a reference to help annotate
the single cell ionic data at the end
you're going to get annotated cell
single cell
cell types
so it has three steps step number one
identify the variable genes amongst cell
types in the reference data set
so you needed to identify the most
different differentially expressed genes
variable genes that are still type
specific in the reference data set and
then correlate those reference
reference data sets with each of the
single cell data
and also the authors wanted to improve
the the
accuracy
to identify the cell types that are
highly identical to each other
so they have iterative refinement
approach which is really nice
so different measures have recently been
benchmarked
and this is one um benchmark study from
our group
where we evaluated over 10 different
methods
to do automatic uh cell type annotation
and we what we found is that single r
and ciret
are the top two best methods
across the board
using different metrics
however one minor
downside of serratus data it is not very
good at identifying rare cell types
automatically
so
there's also another very very important
type of analysis module in single cell
analysis called pseudo time trajectory
analysis
and here i'm showing you an example
method called slingshot it is a it is a
very uh well-cited method
so um
here is a graph to demonstrate how the
slingshot works it has again three steps
first it derives a minimum spanning tree
going through different data points
okay
and then next
it will use it
it derives the simultaneous principal
curves
to smooth
through this different different path
at the end
it projects the single cell data
to this principal curve
and identify the distance between them
so the projected distance then
is called
the pseudo time
pseudo time trajectory
research also has been you know pretty
mature there are many many many methods
out there
as you can see single cell data science
is very prosperous
um
recently
there's a
benchmark method that evaluates them
over 45 different types of
trajectory uh
analysis method and what they found
is consensus wise the two measured
slingshot and the phea they behave the
best especially when they look at the
linear development and also bifurcation
development case
however currently you know most of the
measures don't do so well
when
the pseudo time trajectory have a
circular
circular kind of structure it's very
difficult for those algorithms to pick
up the true signal
so now i just wanted to recap of what we
went through
briefly
on some of the specific modules or
functions of single cell rsc data
analysis
we talked about the normalization we
talked about the gnsl filtering we
talked about the dimension reduction we
talked about the visualization
clustering
and the cell type annotation and study
time reconstruction
so those
are programmable
tools but what about the data portals
data photos
are aimed to
take away the burdens
of users so that they can check the
results quickly and a lot of times for
the end users who don't know how to
program it becomes the only way for them
to do it themselves
one of the big problems of current data
portals are mostly closed platform
meaning that the users cannot really
customize their own pipelines
and even if the users can customize
their own pipelines the developers
cannot contribute their messages
to these
database portals
and also
the different functionality tools
they're coded in different languages
it's very difficult to get them to be
assembled
into some you know uniform um platform
so our solution to this outstanding
issue
is to develop this big uh this
inclusive tool called granite on x
so
we have a unified internal data
structure
to allow the sharing of different
different information between packages
here we call the packages specifically
packages that
perform certain functions as g box it's
wrapped cheap box
and also granite x has a central
repository for well-defined packages
regardless of
how or what program languages those
packages come from
the users can customize their own
pipelines and on the other hand very
importantly the developers can deposit
their own methods into this
meta-analysis tool
so it's very inclusive
it's open to the users it's open to the
developers
and lastly
we care about the efficiency we care
about a scanning app
so this tool can handle largely data
sets
especially when it takes up a lot of
um a lot of single cell size up front as
input data
here is the you know
graph representation of the design idea
behind the granite max
so it really tried to bridge the two
communities biologists and
bioinformaticians
on the front end the biologists can put
in the information
of their single cell data and the
metadata for their samples
and then you can just run through
you know
pipelines that you like to build
yourself
and then you can get a reproducible
results and you can share results with
your collaborators and you can also you
know copy paste the results to put it in
into publications
on the back end
we wrap up different functionalities
into this very essential thing called
g-box
g-box
it has this kind of container based
based approach
and as a result you know the original
module can be written in different
languages
and so we provided the gbox as a
repository like app store
for the users to pick and choose which
ones they wanted to assemble together in
their own pipeline
so you read it provides a lot of
flexibility for the end users
and more
more also
we also aim to make the grand theme x
very
applicable to various types of
computational leads for example you can
you can download it deploy it into your
personal computer
you can use it on the server system and
you can also do the analysis
live on the cloud
this is the interface of quantum x
so when you when you start without a url
and
this is what you see
so you give your introduction of what a
grand max is capable of doing certain
modules
and you can either choose
to use a recommended recipe
meaning pipeline or you start building
your own pipeline either way it's fine
here is a snapshot
of a
user uh
customized
analysis
at the very end the last step to do
pseudo time reconstruction
as you can see you know here is the
recipe that the users assemble
themselves
and here is in the
blog
of you know what kind of modules are
going in there
for example you have umap you have
scampi based clustering you can color
the different samples
and you can identify markers etc etc so
it's very comprehensive
you can add it
you can add modules you can drop modules
anytime you want you can go back and
forth you can restart the analysis
anytime you like
so here's the information of the links
for granted my ex if you want to use the
online web tool this is a link
and if you want to download the source
code you can do that
and also we encourage the developers to
write their own gtbox
in order to advertise their own packages
so now let me move on to open challenges
and perspectives
what i just told you it's still just the
tip of iceberg
single cell data science is very vast
and you know ever-changing field with
increasing complexity every single day
one of the big challenges is to scale up
from the single cell resolution to the
population's resolution
and this idea has been already laid out
in this uh opinion paper 11 grand
challenges in single cell data science
which i really recommend folks to check
it out you know you have single cell
experiments you can have this beautiful
you know trajectory
uh
at a single cell resolution
and then
you have the cell types specific cell
type sub sub sub clusters
and then you're working on top
at the tissue level and then you emerge
to the organs and then populations so
how
can we transverse from very low
resolution to the very high resolution
specifically this is very important for
precision health and precision medicine
so those are wild open questions for the
field
also at the technical level
some other challenges remain for example
how do you do multi-omics data
integration alignment in single cells
so i like to draw the difference between
multi-omega integration versus a
multi-omega alignment what is
multi-omega integration integration
means that you have the technology to be
able to assay different omnics from the
same cells
okay
on the other hand alignment meaning that
you you don't get you do get multiple
types of omics but you don't get them
from the exactly the same cells rather
you get them from different groups of
cells that are highly similar to each
other so those present different
challenges
and we just put out a
review paper
to go over all of the current
multi-omics data integration and
alignment methods in single cells
as you can see here you know it has a
variety of methods
some of them are
matrix factorization based some of them
are neural network based some of them
use networking uh
graph theory etc
but what is lacking right now
is that there hasn't been systematic
benchmarking
evaluating all these different methods
specifically for the multi-ohmic
integration there have been some
alignment benchmark effort going on
already so
because allow me to you know this kind
of technology came out earlier
so what's what's what i expect next is
to
somebody
will
do a systematic comparison of the
different modernics data integration
methods
another
new frontier is spatialomics
so which is also you know
very challenging area to work on
here is a slider to tell you the kind of
variety
already existing in the spatial omics
technology depending on the way the
technology works some of them are next
generation sequencer based some of them
are imaging based within imaging based
methods some of them are using
sequencing approach some of them using
inside choose hybridization approach
so
you end up with very different types of
different different different different
characteristics of the special olympics
data
some of them are targeted
having fewer genes some of them have a
lot of genes
and some of them have a higher
resolution at a single cell level but
some of them don't they're in a group of
cells for example 10x
museum
platform it's not a single cell
resolution but it has spatial resolution
so there's a lot of complexity and
heterogeneity even in terms of the types
of platforms
and the type of data that are generated
in the spatial mix field
and as you see here from one of the
review papers most recently came out
there has been a lot of different types
of analysis you can do
as well
for the special ohmic data just for
special data alone
you will need to do clustering after you
do the cluster
you need to you know characterize which
which
which which clusters belong to what
types of cells
and they need to select the features
that are representative of certain types
of cells
and you need to go back to the spatial
contact to see how those different
functions
are related in the space
and at the end you know some sort of
scoring way to relate back to the to the
to the end users
where is the
hotspot so to speak
so
this is just special omix alone and not
to say
nowadays
studies have start started to do special
omics and also other omics together
so the integration is very very
challenging
another open challenge i think is really
worth visiting is benchmarking
benchmarking we need to know what types
of data sets to use how many data sets
are enough and what are other you know
unbiased reference data sets to use
and for simulation data are we there yet
how well the simulation data can mimic
the reality
and for the metrics what kind of metrics
to use different benchmark studies use
different metrics and some of the
metrics may have some sort of bias one
way or another another
there has to be a very
good agreement across the community and
that needs to be established
and also you know what sorts of methods
you will want to evaluate
you know some of them are not even open
source code a commercial platform so
can you compile around them
the different methods they may have very
different pre-processing steps and that
convolutes
with the performance output
so it's very complex
and more
moreover on top of this
you're currently most of the benchmark
studies they themselves they're ad hoc
they're not evolvable
the truth is that
researchers are going to develop new and
new more and more new measures
and the benchmark studies for the older
methods are going to be
obsolete very quickly
so the benchmark methods are benchmark
studies themselves needed to
evolvable
so that the new when the new message
come out they can just you know easily
compare with what's been done
to speed up the research and the
innovation
and so you know here is one of the few
examples
of so-called cell bench which is the r
package that allows
some sort of regularization to do the
benchmark study and you can you know use
this package for you for future
use as well
so i think effort like this
is really good
to allow the reuse
reusability of the of the code
and making sure that the benchmark
studies that are going to be evolvable
so
here's a summary of my presentation
today single cell data science is a very
fascinating area of research
the data analysis tags are becoming more
and more complex and more and more
challenging
but it is a very great testing ground
for developing and applying and machine
learning research
and lastly i would like to thank my
collaborators and my team members and nh
funding
to allow me to do this kind of research
which is
really cool uh
it evolves every single day thank you so
much
glenn thank you so much for that that
was really a fantastic tour to learn
about uh single cell analytics and the
the various methods um like rna-seq that
are being applied um one of the things
that we in our sequence of
talks have talked a lot about
um
places where
various biases or various distortions of
data may occur that may affect one's
ability to properly interpret and apply
it and i'm kind of curious in your
experience
where potentially given that there's so
many different processing steps with
each one being a potential to introduce
some degree of bias i'm curious about
your perception of where those might be
and what can be done about it
that's a really wonderful question great
question
so you know
right now
most of the benchmark studies they're
evaluating one function
at one time
so they really don't
they take it like a in silo approach to
evaluate okay for example if i wanted to
divide a clustering i care about that
but the pro steps before clustering
may
not be the variations the bias come out
from the pre-processing steps are not
really uh being
recapitulated in that way
so i think
you know
every you're right you're absolutely
right every single process stable
could very well introduce bias right
every time we do some
dimension reduction you're actually
reducing the data complexity
so
there is definitely some sort of
uh interactions
go consequences or impact among
different steps data processing steps
and currently this is a really rare you
know
people don't really pay too much
attention about it but the the fact that
that's so important we really need to
step back and look at a heuristic
you know rather than benchmarking
individual
steps or modules
should we benchmark
all the pipelines within the pipelines
there has been many different ways of
doing since so the do the flows
so i think more
holistic approach
would be very important to really
evaluate
where the interactions
happens where the bias
you know come out from which step is
most dominant and how we can avoid them
yeah i think you know the longer your
processing workflow becomes
the the more the greater distance if you
will there is between your result and
the original data if you will and as
that distance is kind of you know
pushed further and further with all the
different methodologies you know you
mentioned about all the different data
reduction techniques that people have
attempted to apply every one of those
that one applies
you know moves the data a little bit
further from what was actually collected
and it's all very exciting because as
you point out so rightly so there's just
a rich area of opportunity to develop
methods and to process the data in
clever ways but some of those may be you
know maybe
the result of some bias that happened in
an earlier step or they're introducing a
bias which some other subsequent step
picks up and runs with and so these are
just things that i'm just kind of
curious about
yes i i see your point you know you we
what people mostly are doing well an
analogy is you're looking at a local
maximum
local open moon but you're not looking
at a global optimum
so that's what i see the problem right
now
with those different evaluation tools
yeah um
are there any groups who are attempting
to develop um standards or sets of best
practice for how people report studies
in single cell
data analytics that might help to
provide at least some guard rails to
keep people from straying too far off
into the margins and presenting stuff
that's not reproducible or may have
biases in them or anything like that
um i think that there is general sense
the you know uh interpret for example
benchmarking there has been publications
a group of people um
where they laid out like 10 different
rules that you need to consider in terms
of collecting the data what kind of data
what kind of data sets you
include in the benchmarking
what kind of metrics that you can use
how do you evaluate the you know wreck
those methods and et cetera
so there are some you know concepts
there recommendations so to speak a
guideline recommendation
but i think in terms of
standardization particularly in single
cell field right now it's still
kind of wild west
yeah so i think the the the the issue
there is that you know
the technology has been
going so fast right if it's not a speed
of the light but it it's definitely
changing every single day
and because technology is changing every
single day so the the that data
analytical folks
most majority of them
are running after those technologies and
figure out how to analyze it you know
how to develop a new method normal
method so to speak the performance best
on the user's data so that's where most
effort is and then over time all people
start to realize wait a minute there are
so many measures being developed we need
to have some way to evaluate them
because we ourselves we don't know which
ones to use so they have a benchmark
effort however even in the benchmark
studies there are shortcomes there
there's problems weakness of issues as
well
so i i feel like
now needs to have some sort of metaphor
of a benchmark to have some sort of
standardization
um
you know one of the things that
i'm thinking is back in the microwave
space there is this kind of qc community
right that was that happened to evaluate
the systematically
um different platforms
and you know
genomic
genomic scientists have been doing the
systematic uh comparison of the
different
uh methods uh experimental methods so
there has been effort to do that and i
think there are some really good uh
standards there but in terms of the
computational aspect
i still think
we have a long way to go you know even
for benchmark studies themselves they're
not
really easy to be adapted for the future
use so that's one big problem right
i'm also curious about the role of
reference data sets um you know we're
often doing things where we take a
sample of you know some someone's dna
and we're comparing it against a
reference
dna data set to look for insertions or
deletions or single nucleotide
polymorphisms et cetera et
um
but if there's any you know those very
often those reference data sets are from
a single individual who happens to be
rich and famous
and so there may be a little bias in
there right um or they're not
necessarily population based or or
represent sometimes they are but not not
always representative of uh of the
broader
world population they may be
you know there's a some ascerta kind of
um
acquisition bias or various other things
which creep in i'm curious about the
role of those reference databases as a
as a source of potential conflict there
that is also just also an issue because
you know um i mean you know for for for
the sleeps the geos community you know
genetics community recently there has
been one paper coming out i think they
were using your population based
reference panel now rather than one
reference right um but in a single cell
field
you know
they're still just trying to
get the athletes going
um there is this community human style
us if you're studying human tissues so
there there is a community
that collects if you are part of the
community then you contribute to your
data as part of the adolescent uh
consortium
um
in human cell advice it focuses on the
normal normal normal tissues not to
tissues so petitioning that's a good
place
to to to to start with a reference
but again you know right now i think
because because it's a community
voluntary community how many
how many people you need to
collect as samples for reference
how do you control
the other
confounders
in the population heterogeneity you know
for the epidemiologist
know very well the human populations are
very different
so how do you control
the population level heterogeneity i
think
probably it's starting to think you know
like people like me were thinking about
it but obviously i'm not the one who's
designing this experiment yet but i
think the two community needs to somehow
start to talk to each other
and and and definitely i think the folks
are interested to know you know what
would be
a good reference
um you know
right now i think one
the best reference that have been
generated
in the in the in the human tissues is
probably in the blood that one has a lot
of samples
it's more or less similar if you look at
them but of course when you compare
different different people's
data you need to do some alignment but
more or less pvmc cells
they are they're more or less similar
but if you look at some other tissues
there are definitely individual level
difference
so
how do you control those kind of
individual level difference how do you
have enough
representation
for the so-called norm
i think that's an open question you know
the whole community needs to come in and
especially
uh human cell a lot of folks needed to
perhaps
think about them where is their next
roadmap now we started them you know
this big project and collecting all the
human tissues and then
how many would be enough
uh some sort of experimentation maybe
wrong simulation
this is just my wild guess
you have collected some pilot samples
and you could do wrong simulation to see
based on those examples to see at what
point you reach this situation at what
point is the variation it's not going to
be much different anymore
it's not going to cause big change in
terms downstream analysis
well it sounds like there is still a lot
of work to do but it's very exciting and
like i just as you kind of point out in
your talk there's just a lot of room for
methods development however there's a
lot of things to be kind of wary of and
make sure to
uh as
bioinformaticians and people developing
ai solutions and machine learning
different sources of
variance of bias of other things to be
kind of accounted for so
atlantic garmer from university of
michigan thank you so much for joining
us today and sharing your work and
sharing this uh summary of single cell
data processing and bioinformatics has
been wonderful having a chat with you
today thank you so much
my great pleasure thank you so much
thank you
thank you and everyone remember that
monday afternoon is the last time when
you can apply for our biomedical data
science innovation lab and i hope you do
everyone have a great weekend we'll see
you next week bye now bye